you thought what you just saw you know
is a G and this is build your squad this
is my all-time dunk contest okay first
and foremost I think we're all in
agreement
$5.00 goes to my man Vince Carter right
there first and foremost he did the
Super Fly so clean and the Superfly is a
reverse 360 windmill perfect to a tee
that's one of the hardest dunks ever
second that boy a G you know what he
means to me is two of the top five best
dance of all the time
[Applause]
alright alright moving on moving on you
know I like a lot of these Duncan's in
the fight for but I gotta conserve my
bread a little bit so we're gonna go for
2t Ross let's see here he did a 360
behind the back which is super tough to
do and he's the teammate got us on love
yeah super balanced you went baseline
you did the Kobe pump finish on the
other side which is super cold how much
money I got left
oh I'm already at 3 right oh yeah then
you guys go that you guys that we should
put forth no revenge it's all love it's
all competition and collaboration so
that's gonna be a hell of a dunk on you
got Vince Carter T Ross me and Zack
Lavine all in the dunk contest oh my
goodness get out of here man people
gonna be rockin who we were talking
about that dunk contest like to talk
about the 2016 don't crunch it it's
gonna be crazy
all right cool yeah thanks that's fine
what's up with this $15 who's this go to